[Applaudissements]
voilà les questions 4/3 de jean luc
lemoine on sait que vous les attendez
mais pour le moment on va passer au
trophée des animateurs sépare
[Applaudissements]
historique puisque pour la première fois
vous m'entendez bien pour la première
fois des huit en direct va maintenant
célébrer les animateurs les plus
antipathiques
[Applaudissements]
j'ai cette cérémonie je ne vais pas le
faire seuls les trois premiers nommés
seront là dans quelques instants
mais pour remettre ce prix je tenais à
avoir quelqu'un d'emblématique car c'est
lui qui dirige l'association des
animateurs antipathique depuis des
années maintenant
il a été lui-même j'appelle le grand
nelson monfort qui est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
le soleil c'est les boules
biden une première question en tant que
président vous même des animateurs
antibiotiques en douze heures
qu'est ce que représente ce trophée ça
change une carrière quand même alors je
crois que c'est l'aboutissement c'est
l'aboutissement de toute carrière je
suis très heureux de présider cette
association je pense ne va cesser de
grandir surtout surtout après qu'on vous
aura annoncé les trois lauréats de ce
soir attention lesquels il y à vraiment
des surprises mais je pense que nous
serons en bonne compagnie mon cher
julien parce que vous avez oublié de
dire également que vous étiez le vice
présidente c'est assez cher évidemment
le chroniqueur avec tout le monde
bien sûr l'émotion est palpable il est
grand temps d'appeler le premier celui
qui est classé numéro 3 dont on peut
rappeler le palmarès récent essor
extraordinaire son palmarès est tout à
fait impressionnant puisque on ne compte
pas le nombre de chaînes sur lesquelles
il a travaillé pour la chaîne le nombre
de chaînes sur lesquelles il n'a pas
travaillé qu'ils sont beaucoup moins
nombreuses
donc il a successivement travaillé sur
m6 sur tf1 sur d8 il hérisse le poil et
stings 13% des français séduit c'est
bien qu'il est très aimé par 87% des
français ce qui n'est rien de dire qu'on
comprend mieux que vous soyez présidents
d'associations quand on vous entend que
mal à vous même d'appeler maintenant
qu'à vous le savez nous sommes en direct
au jardin et il faut appeler le numéro 3
qui est autre que
ivanov
chez soi
mais c'est son père
installez-vous jouant plus sur l'a 13 du
métro ça doit être quand même
terriblement émouvant pour un père
d'avoir un fils consacré comme étant
l'un des animateurs les plus détestés en
france quelle est votre première
impression
je suis très déçu qu'il ne soit que
troisième mais très déçu mais c'est un
peu ma faute j'ai mal élevé j'ai appelé
à dire au revoir merci
j'aurais dû lui dire d'envoyer balader
tout le monde aurait été fini premier
soit autant qu'à être antipathique au
temps à te 1er mai ce que ses fins est
ce que dans la famille des gens lui
inculquer ces valeurs là tout petit de
tout petits s'était élevé à la brutale
maire jean-pierre public want to know
what was you get enough bendjama
punitions corporelles jeu on me signale
qu'il faut passer au deuxième exposé des
gens veulent savoir de mahler ou deux
récits le saut à la deuxième place oui
c'est une phénoménale surprise puisque
il hérisse le poil il angoisse plus de
17% des autonomes
c'était et c'est vrai qu'il ya 83 % des
français qu'ils adorent ce qui n'est
rien n'est ce pas et c'est un véritable
professionnel de la tan assez de la race
rhin les intéressés en comprimant il
s'agit de quelqu'un qui débute un petit
peu qui n'est pas encore très connu dans
ce studio c'était fulgurant quelques
mots il a réussi à agacer toute la
france c'est pour ça qu'il est là ce
soir monsieur cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
si quelques mois pour tous ces gens qui
vous ont détesté que vous voulez
remercier maintenant c'est surtout ce
soir je suis à la fois heureux heureux
parce que je fais mon entrée dans le top
3 et c'est vrai que voilà j'espérais
faire mon entrée dans le top 3 depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant je suis
néanmoins déçu parce que là parce que je
voulais c'est la voilà la place de
numéro un
les prochains noms dans l'année
prochaine j'aurais voulu que ce soit
cette année c'est encore l'autre qu'il a
eue là on n'en révèle pas je sais mais
il a eu voilà donc je sans doute comme
un bruit non je vais essayer de faire
tout ça secoue prochaine
monfils l'a battu il ya deux trois ans
dames on avait quand même pour battre le
numéro 1 vous avez de la concurrence
je vais faire le maximum j'ai essayé de
faire le maximum l'année prochaine pour
être encore plus lourd voilà et je vais
demander à thierry moreau voilà deux de
s'occuper de moi pendant toute l'année
dans la centre le classement est très
serré puisque ray 17% pour la médaille
d'argent
médaille d'argent qui sera remis dans
quelques instants et 18% seulement pour
la médaille d'or donc il a été élu de
justesse l'animateur le plus
antipathique celui que 18% des français
ne peuvent pas souffrir sévir kiana 82
qu'il a décroché de l'agacement les
enfants à la télé le décor pencher des
merveilles fait pour emmerder ceux qui
les regardent
il est là ce soir c'est le grand arthur
le numéro
en cela vous
merci oui
je crois que place à l'émotion arthur
tout de suite je vois votre sort et que
vous aviez envie de reconquérir cette
place que vous aviez perdu faut dire
qu'un ces dix dernières années j'ai été
huit fois premier et j'ai eu une petite
traversée du désert depuis décembre j'ai
eu un petit passage à vide puisque
l'année dernière ces droits je crois
qu'il y avait sept points du podium mais
voilà donc voilà